اخر حول الذكاء الاصطناعي الانتخابات قد
تكون في خطر وبسبب المعلومات المضلله
والمحتوى المزيف الذي قد يتم انشاؤه مع
امكانيه استخدام الذكاء الاصطناعي كوقودا
عاطفي يؤثر على توجهات الناخبين قد يكون
ذلك خطابا او بيانا صحفيا او صوره او نكته
او فيديو يروج لفوائد مرشح على حساب اخر
مثال بسيط قبل شهر استخدمت اللجنه الوطنيه
التابعه للحزب الجمهوري الامريكي تقنيه
لتصميم فيديو لتدعيه مرعبه في حال اعاده
انتخاب بايدن
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الامر ليس خاصا فقط بالانتخابات الامريكيه
فحوالي مليار ناخب يتوجهون العام المقبل
الى صناديق الاقتراع في جميع انحاء
الولايات المتحده الهند والاتحاد الاوروبي
واندونيسيا وروسيا وبريطانيا
لم يخفي رئيس الوزراء ريشسوناك طموحه بان
يجعل المملكه المتحده قوه عظمى في مجال
الذكاء الاصطناعي ولكن رغم تعالي الاصوات
لتقنين هذه التكنولوجيا التي تشهد تطورا
سريعا اكتفت الحكومه البريطانيه بانها
ستقود الحد من مخاطر الذكاء الاصطناعي
معتمده على اللوائح الحاليه بدلا من ادخال
ما تسميه بالتشريعات القاسيه الخانقه
للابتكار خبراء حذروا من ان الانتخابات
المقبله يمكن ان تتميز بموجه من المعلومات
الخاطئه المدعومه بالذكاء الاصطناعي ما لم
تتعامل الحكومه بسرعه مع هذه التكنولوجيا
التي قد تهدد البشريه فريق عمل يعنى
بنماذج الذكاء الاصطناعي الاساسيه سيرسي
دائما الاستخدام الامن للنماذج الذكيه في
مختلف قطاعات الاقتصاد التي قد ترفع
الناتج المحليه باكثر من 10% بحلول 2030
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات